[Music]
hello everyone my name is Hong Yi I'm
here to talk about GSI the generic
system images GSI is by definition the
purest form of android framework that we
can build from AOSP by purist we mean
that it doesn't contain any device maker
or carrier customization you you will
want to ask OSP has been there for 10
years why does it become a thing right
now it is because GSI is the central
piece in tribal compliance so remember
the project rebel we took out the
Android update ability problem with
rebel about two years ago in the oriole
timeframe we re are connected Android to
have a clear boundary between the
android framework and the hardware
related a vendor implementation with
this boundary clearly defined we no
longer need to update the vendor
implementation with the android
framework so this has greatly reduced
the cost and time for device maker to
update their android framework now to
make sure that the boundary is not
altered by device makers at will we
require every tribal certified device to
pass a set of CDs and videos tests with
their android framework replaced by GSI
so with all these powerful tools in
place about a year ago we started to see
the momentum of faster android by
adoption this
year so let's take a look at the enjoy
beta program at Google i/o last year
only Nexus and pixel phones were
available for for you to try out Android
or real and fast forward one year later
at coil this year it was the first time
ever that we had non-google phones to
join the beta lineup and it's now one
it's not - it's seven device makers
joining us so the progress was
phenomenal we know we are on the right
track and we will continue to push for
it now despite that GSI is the central
piece in tribal compliance we feel that
it has a lot more potential than that
so we set out a goal to make GSI be more
accessible and useful not just for
device makers but also for the general
public including app developers like you
and even consumers an important first
step toward that goal is to make GSI
available in LSP so for this we have
published PI GSI in USB so now you can
download and build PI 3si today we are
also exploring ways to make future GSI
available earlier than the release of
next Android version so you will be able
to try out next century version earlier
over GSI and at the same time we can
also get early feedback from you so the
benefit is mutual so please stay tuned
for our further announcement on this
finally
we understand that trying out GSI can be
cumbersome sometimes we are looking into
different ways to improve the process
right now we have an idea of trying out
GSI without actually flashing GSI under
the device but I'm not going into detail
here we do have a working early
prototype at our demo booth in addition
to that we also prepare a set of devices
they are all running on the same PI GSI
so please do check out our demos at the
Android platform sandbox
[Music]